bonjour avoue christian jacob bonjour
merci d'être avec nous ce matin tout
change depuis le début la vème
république
les hommes les gouvernements les parties
mais il ya une chose qui ne change pas
ou presque
à une exception près le sénat à la fin
c'est la droite gagne et vous avez gagné
hier on renouveler la moitié des sièges
lr garde la majorité les verts vont
pouvoir former un groupe et la
république en marche limite la casse en
obtenant l'élection de deux ministres
sébastien lecornu et jean-baptiste
lemoyne qui deviennent donc sénateurs
quelle analyse faites vous de ces de ses
résultats d'hier
d'abord on renoue avec la victoire pour
ce qui est de la droite je rappelle que
depuis huit ans on a perdu deux
présidentielles de législatives un échec
cinglant européenne
nous avons gagné les municipales c'est à
dire que sur le les élections
territoriales les français ont fait
confiance au candidat de droite et
notamment aux candidats les républicains
et les élections sénatoriales c'est le
prolongement cirque eux on gagne 10
sièges au sénat
ça n'est pas rien ça n'est pas
anecdotique et c'est ce qui va nous
permettre de nous préparer aux autres
échéances territoriales au départemental
et aux régionales les sénateurs françois
patriat et sébastien lecornu de la
république en marche sont à la manoeuvre
pour essayer de débaucher des membres du
groupe ait l'air de les attirer dans
leur groupe
yves a combien qui vont basculer aucun
tout ça est ridicule c'est de la petite
politique politicienne
monsieur lecornu d'ailleurs été
sévèrement secoué dans son département
il arrivait en deuxième position c'est
les républicains qui sont qui sont
arrivés en tête je pense qu'il faut
qu'ils arrêtent avec ses petites
combines
tout cela parce qu il l est de la
situation que nous avons à laquelle nous
faisons face aujourd'hui nécessite un
peu plus de dignité et de hauteur à la
vie politique
aussi n'at il faut donc que tout change
pour que rien ne change ce gérard
larcher candidat à sa propre réélection
n'aurait pu espérer je sais pas moi une
femme n'en coûtait moi je souhaite une
très belle réaction à gérard larcher
suis convaincu que ce sera ce sera le
cas quand on a un excellent président du
sénat on le garde
bon allez christian jacob trois jours
après l'attentât qui a visé l'ancien
immeuble de charlie hebdo à paris on
reçoit le monsieur terrorisme lors en
une aide à 8h20 tout à l'heure le risque
terroriste est il était sous-évalué oui
oui il a clairement été sous-évalués
rien n'est fait depuis trois ans rien
regarder ce qui vient de se passer sur
les mineurs isolés
la cire en 2012 on accueillait la france
accueillait mille miller est isolé
aujourd'hui on a quarante mille 40 fois
plus qu'il ya eu la crise pardon il ya
eu la guerre en serrant au moyeu et il
est l'afflux de 40 fois plus ce n'est
pas rien avec la plupart de ces mineurs
qui n'en sont pas la réalité c'est que
vraisemblablement on va apprendre dans
l'est dans les heures qui viennent que
l'auteur de l'attentât n'était en
réalité pas un mineur il était
accueillie comme telle à lorsque vous
dites effectivement on va se faire
confirmer par là en une el milia des
informations qui disent qu'ils n'avaient
pas 18 ans mais plutôt 25 ans et
nouvelle identité de l'homme et tout ça
on va le vérifier et accueillir comme
mineurs isolés et pourquoi on ne fait
rien on peut aujourd'hui faire des tests
osseux simplement pour faire ces tests
il faut l'accord de l'intéressé une
décision judiciaire autant dire qu'il ya
aucun test qui sent qu'ils sont réalisés
de la même façon que le président de la
république sur ce sujet de l'islamisme
radical d'abord ils n'arrivent pas
prononcer le nom c'est une réalité
lidl les victimes aujourd'hui plus de
260 victimes depuis depuis 2012 ils sont
pas victimes de je ne sais trop quel
séparatisme ils sont victime de
l'islamisme radical
le président de la république est
incapable de se prononcer sur ce sujet
il n'arrive pas à prononcer avec tous
les trois mois il nous annonce un grand
disque ans je vais vous dire mayenne il
avait un grand discours là théoriquement
c'est le 2 c'est à dire vendredi
quels mots souhaitez vous entendre dans
la bouche du président la république
quel mêlée confuse engagements qu'on en
finisse avec les mots simplement qu'il
prenne des décisions
c'est ce qu'on lui demande or rien n'est
fait il est je sais pas tétanisé par ce
sujet incapable de décider sur sur quoi
que ce soit le sujet des mineurs isolés
tous les départements le le savent bien
il n'y a pas un président de conseil
départemental qui n'est pas fort mais
cela la situation aujourd'hui des des
individus qui sont fichés au fichier de
prévention contre le radicalisme 20000
non 3400 qui sont étrangers qui sont
toujours sur le sol français
or ils sont en lien avec des réseaux
islamistes
les mosquées salafistes mille mosquées
salafistes ray
répertoriés en france de mémoire je
crois que c'était deux de fermer
temporairement en 2010 8,5 en 2019
aucune depuis le début de l'année au
plus loin sur la fermeture de deux cent
cinquante lieux suspects ça peut être
des mosquées ça peut être des salles de
prières et ça peut être des bars à
chicha
c'est ça qui est cesser les chiffres
annoncés par jean alarmes non oui pour
le moment absolument rien n'a été fait
et est donc vous attendez la fermeté on
attend des décisions très claires du
président de la république et qu'il
fasse vous savez dans ce dans ce domaine
un peu plus de rigueur un peu plus de
sérieux et un peu moins d'arrogance dans
le verbe alors autre sujet les mesures
de restriction entre en vigueur ce soir
à marseille dans plusieurs grandes
villes les restaurateurs et les
propriétaires de bars ne décolère pas
vous leur dites quoi ce matin christian
jacob il faut être responsable
il faut accepter les mesures pour
endiguer endiguer l'épidémie bien sûr
qu'il faut être responsable mais pour
rondo a aussi tiré les enseignements de
ce qui s'est passé il ya six mois c'est
à dire un état qui réagit dans
l'affolement général en ascension pas
les collectivités territoriales en
associant pas les organisations
professionnelles
eh bien on arrive à des décisions qui
sont incomprises et inefficace or là je
pense qu' il y aurait pu avoir une
négociation avec les les collectivités
territoriales que ce soit les villes les
départements les régions mais aussi avec
les organisations professionnelles dans
un certain nombre de domaines
je pense qu'on peut prendre des mesures
de protection pourquoi on laisse ouvert
les restaurants ferment les bars et on
peut prendre des exemples comme ça à
l'infini il me semble que les
organisations professionnelles sont
prêts à faire des affaires des efforts
ils l'ont déjà fait il ya du civisme il
faut arrêter de dire que c'est de la
faute aux français qu'on n'est pas
responsable dira vous promener comme moi
dans les rues de paris les gens portent
le masque
chacun est attentif à la distanciation
pardon vous comprenez un renaud muselier
qui déposent un recours en référé pour
faire annuler ces décisions vous
comprenez une samia ghali qui affirme
que la police municipale ne verbalisera
pas les bars et les restaurants qui
resteront ouverts vous comprenez ces
réactions d'élus qui sont des élus ray
mika ou c'est de la démagogie non c'est
pas la démagogie mais ils en ont
ras-le-bol d'être pris pour des
imbéciles
avec un président de la république à
premier ministre dit territoire toutes
les trois phrases mais qui est incapable
en réalité d'avoir de partager une
décision vous savez il y avait quand
j'étais chez les jeunes agriculteurs on
avait une référence qui venait de l'ajac
et jeunesse agricole chrétienne c'était
voir juger agir
ça veut dire qu'il faut dans un premier
temps partagé un constat est donc
pourquoi ce constat n'est pas partagée
avec les responsables territoriaux et
qu'ensemble on prend les décisions qui
s'imposent personne ne fuit l'obstacle
les collectivités territoriales les
responsables d'établissements publics en
sont conscients simplement on leur
impose des décisions sans discussion sur
orient leur dit c'est comme ça et pas
autrement et surtout qu'ils soient
attentifs aux chaînes info parce que ils
savent que dans deux heures dans deux
jours tout peut changer parce que là
aussi ça veut dire quoi être attentif
aux chaînes d'info ben parce que c'est
de cette manière dont ils ont les
informations le maire de marseille
apprend les informations par les chaînes
infos et les apprend par la voix directe
par le débat la discussion avec le
premier ministre rapidement de questions
pour terminer le budget 2021 budget très
impactées par le cos vite sera présenté
demain vous avez entendu dominique seux
hors norme des déficits qui seront à
plus de 10% du pib la droite
traditionnellement soucieuse de
maintenir les comptes publics se tait
vous allez voter ce budget vous n'avez
rien à dire sur les consuls itil on l'a
où on l'a dit à plusieurs à plusieurs
reprises la situation dans laquelle est
là et la france si elle est si
particulière mais c'est parce qu'aucune
réforme n'était porté depuis trois
centres la réalité des choses on a le
pire des avants qu'ovide nous avions le
pire déficit commercial de la zone euro
le pire déficit public qui firent pardon
avant que vides le déficit de cette
année va être de 2,2 pour ce 3 2 3%
rond-point du tri-nations y miser sur
2,2 vite sur cette année bon il ya eu le
vide non mais d'accord simplement aucune
réforme
rien n'a été fait incapable de faire une
réforme des retraites trois ans pour ne
pas faire de réformes
je rappelle que quand la droite était au
pouvoir c'était la réforme des retraites
qui a été menée la loi tepa pour
l'exonération des la fiscalisation des
menteurs dernière question vous allez
déjeuner cette semaine avec elle
bertrand vous l'aviez pas vu depuis
qu'il a claqué la porte du parti à trois
ans xavier bertrand a su mettre près de
candidats pour 2022 question simple
réponse simple christian jacob pourriez
vous soutenir un candidat qui
n'appartient plus à votre parti il a dit
qu'il appartenait à notre famille
politique mais le sujet n'est pas là on
n'est pas dans le temps de la
présidentielle
on est aujourd'hui dans le temps des
territoriales nous venons de gagner les
sénatoriales nous allons nous préparer
aux départementales ou régionales
travailler sur le fond présenter un
projet aux français et viendra le temps
de la présidentielle le temps n'est pas
venu ça s'appelle botter en touche nord
mais le temps n'est pas venu remercier
les jeunes hommes merci les a tout à
l'heure il est 7 heures